welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital images
part one the basics in this video we're
going to take a look at how
a computer display works we'll also take
a look at some different aspects of
computer displays
and televisions and so these might be
useful if you were to go
shopping for a new computer or a new
television
the next video will take a very close
look at how colors generated
for now even though some of the examples
i have
will use color images we're going to
defer the discussion of how the color
actually works until the next video
let's start off by taking a look at a
typical computer screen
if we take a look at a computer screen
and we get a magnifying glass in order
to look
very closely at the screen what we'll
discover is that the screen is actually
composed
of a gigantic grid in our black and
white case
each of the grid elements can either be
on or off
and by turning individual pixels on or
off
we can actually generate a particular
image so in this case
i've turned on a number of pixels in the
top left-hand corner
and you can see that this is forming the
letter h
each of these individual grid elements
is what we refer to as a picture element
or for short
pixel
in the black and white case each pixel
is backed by an individual bit somewhere
in computer memory and if that bit is on
then the corresponding pixel is on and
if that bit is off then the
corresponding pixel is off
one thing that you might want to look at
when you're considering purchasing a
computer or
a television is the screen resolution
the screen resolution is
how many pixels wide and how many pixels
tall
a particular display is here are some
sample screen resolutions
a surface book 15 inches
pixels across and 1 64 pixels
down a macbook pro 15 inches
3072 pixels from left to right and
1920 pixels from top to bottom
here's an interesting example that a
friend of mine purchased this is a 34
inch ultra wide monitor it is 3440
pixels
wide by 1440 pixels tall
and then finally here's a 55 inch high
definition television
it is 1920 pixels wide and
1080 pixels tall some of these different
screen resolutions have
names that you may occasionally hear so
for example
one of the older resolutions is 640 by
480.
um this is used both by older computers
and older televisions
i mentioned this because 640 by 480 for
computers was referred to as vga
and you will still hear this name
occasionally
usually in conjunction with connectors
for monitors that were used back in
the vga days and in fact are still in
use today
many classrooms at stanford still have
vga connections
and here's a photograph showing you what
a vga cable looks like
for televisions the same resolution
640x480 is referred to as 480i
or 480p and we'll be talking in the next
video about what the i and the p
actually stands for that 3440 by
1440 pixel monitor
that's referred to as an ultra wide and
then here's another one that you will
commonly hear
1920 pixels by 1080 pixels is referred
to as hdtv
for high definition television or it's
sometimes referred to as 1080p
one important quality to consider when
we're looking at a monitor
or television is the aspect ratio
the aspect ratio is the ratio between
the width of the display and the height
of this the display in pixels
when we're talking about computer
displays or televisions this is always
given us a ratio of two whole numbers
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take the number of pixels wide and
the number of pixels tall
and try and come up with the smallest
pair of integer numbers
that gives us the exact same ratio let's
take a look at an example
here we have a monitor that's 1024
pixels wide and 768 pixels tall
if we wanted to come up with a the
lowest possible integer numbers
giving us the same relationship between
the width and the height
it turns out if we take the 10 24 and we
divide it by the 256
that's going to give us the integer
number 4 and we take the 768 and
we divide it by the 256 that gives us
the integer number three
and so we would say that this particular
display is
a four by three display
to use another example if we take a look
at our 1920 by 1080
high definition television and again
looking for the
smallest pair of integer numbers that
gives us the exact same ratio
what we would do is we take the 1920 we
divide it by 120
and that would give us 16 and we would
take the 1080 and divide
that by the same 120 and that would give
us the integer nine and so we would say
that
the aspect ratio of an hd television is
16 by nine
now notice while these aspect ratios are
directly related to the screen
resolution they are not
the same here we see three different
displays that
all have the same four to three aspect
ratio and yet we can see that they have
wildly different numbers of pixels
the largest box represents a 27 inch
old-school
crt television which would be 640
pixels by 480 pixels and we also see a
12.9 inch ipad pro
this has many many more pixels 2732
by 2048 and then finally we have a 7.9
inch ipad mini which is
2048 by 1536.
all three of these if you work them out
are four by three
and yet the number of pixels is quite
different and you can actually see that
the number of pixels is not directly
related to the size of the screens
we'll be talking about that a little bit
later
so what's the best aspect ratio well
it actually depends on what you're
planning to use the device for
and how large the device is let's first
take a look at
what sort of device we might want to use
if we're trying to get some work done
here's a large 27-inch 16x9 monitor you
can see that
with this monitor it's quite wide and we
can very comfortably see two documents
side by side
so for work purposes a widescreen
large monitor works really really well
on the other hand let's take a quick
look at a comparison between
two different tablets
our tablet on the left is a samsung
galaxy tab s4
this is a 16x10 and on the right we have
an ipad pro
you can see with the ipad pro we can
actually see a fair amount more of the
document and in fact
the samsung galaxy tab is a 16 by 10
instead of a 16x9 they used to make 16x9
tablets but
they were so short that people just
couldn't get much work done on them
and so they have moved to 16x10 but you
can see from this image here this
comparison here that the ipad's four by
three ratio
does get us more of a document so we're
interested in viewing
documents on our small screen tablet
you know that 16x9 wide screen is not
necessarily the best choice
on the other hand if we're interested in
entertainment for most types of
entertainment
that 16 by 10 or 16 by nine is going to
work really great let's take a look at
that next
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to take a look at our 16 by 9
and our 4x3 screen ratios let's say
we've got a
small size 4x3 ipad
and we've got a large screen 16x9
hd tv now when we're looking at
movies and television they also have
aspect ratio and so ideally what we like
is the aspect ratio of
our screen to match the aspect ratio of
our film or television
now there's a couple things you need to
know first of all the aspect ratios
given
in film and television do not use whole
integers instead they use decimal
numbers so
for example instead of having 4 by 3 or
16 by 9
we might get something like 2.35 to 1 or
1.85 to 1
so they actually use those decimals the
other thing is
we need to know what happens when the
aspect ratio of our
device does not meet the aspect ratio of
our media and what's going to happen is
we're either going to get letterbox
which means that
the media will occupy the center of our
screen and then above and below that
media we'll get black bars
or we'll get pillar box which means that
the media will again
occupy the center of our screen and on
the left and the right we're going to
get black bars
so this is what's going to happen when
things don't match let's start off with
an action movie captain america civil
war now action movies
really like taking full advantage of the
widescreen and so we're going to see
that
action movies have very wide aspect
ratios and are going to have
large amounts of letterbox on the top
and bottom
so for our hdtv the http is already
pretty wide
so the letterbox above and below those
black bars above and below
aren't that big but they are still
present
in contrast with the ipad you can see
that there are much much thicker black
bars on the top and bottom and that's
because the aspect ratio of the ipad
does not match
captain america's aspect ratio nearly as
well as the http does
here's another action movie this is the
fellowship of the ring from 2001
this has the same aspect ratios captain
america are roughly the same
aspect ratio as captain america both of
these and most action movies are
somewhere around 2.35 to 1.
and again it's a bit wider than even our
widescreen televisions
in contrast if we look at dramas these
actually are quite close to
our hdtv standard this is sense and
sensibility from 1996 this is 1.85 to 1.
and this matches almost perfectly with
our widescreen television so
um if you've got a widescreen television
and you're watching a drama like sense
and sensibility it's going to fit just
about perfectly
in contrast on our ipad again we can
still see
the black bars on the top and the bottom
this is up from pixar 2009
again very similar same aspect ratio
sense and sensibility
so these dramas are going to look really
great on an hd television there's not
going to be any letterboxing at all
we will get a bit of letterboxing on an
ipad now
earlier i talked about how the sandstone
galaxy tab
didn't work quite as well as the ipad's
4x3 ratio
for getting actual work done reading
documents well
this would work perfectly for these
movies so
if you're buying a tablet to watch media
then the 16 by 10 would work great if
you're buying a tablet to get work done
then maybe the 4x3 ipad ratio works
better
finally let's look at take a look at
some older media
this is the friends television show from
the 1990s
this has a four by three ratio so this
fits perfectly on our ipad
but when we place it on hd television it
doesn't fit
so what's going to happen is we're going
to have to place black bars on the left
and the right
and again this is sometimes referred to
as pillar box
and then finally if we have an old
school movie like say the wizard of oz
from 1939 or casablanca from 1943
these are going to be very similar to
friends these have a 1.37 to 1 ratio
whereas france has a 1.33 to 1 ratio but
it's just about the same
and it's going to fit perfectly or
almost perfectly on a 4x3 ipad
but again with our hd television we're
going to have to
have those pillar bars on the right and
left
alright our next video is going to take
a look at how computers generate color
you